anything about that look normal to its
recommend if happy well there's no
coming back from that Calvin it's me Bob
Sarge I'm million Robbie we're dick from
high school look at you most like 200
pounds what you do I just did one thing
I need to know I worked out six hours a
day every day for the last 20 years
straight you should know one thing about
I'm in the CIA are you joking with me
right now
I got a plan
might get us both killed but if it works
it'll be a totally boss story cool three
weeks ago an enemy of the state who
stole the encryption keys to the entire
US by a satellite program
I need your super sweet accounting
skills to help me figure out the last
piece of this puzzle like a chocolate
don't do it stop it stop you would pull
this guy in school you're my only friend
Calvin you're the only one in this whole
world that I trust now that you're in
I'm not in I know but they think you're
ready but I'm not probably one of those
perception versus reality things
happening right now
Oh
was coffee ticket not that one oh my god
oh you chose to be an international
CIA's fighters on a lark Bullers
you're like Jason Bourne and George
you remember those backflips used to do
let's do the flip
that was so close
tonight shy smile fine nation is half
diner face titanum do you Santa fire
vets all right nice mother lost ninety